if you couldn't tell we are now in the
panel
all right we did it
um
cool so i'm gonna start off by
um asking some hopefully not to broader
the questions to our uh
our panelists and then uh
at some point you know um
maybe transition to the but i think uh
i i generally you know
i don't want to be like that moderator
where then someone's like why didn't you
let the people talk i'm gonna have
policy like
if in somehow in the course of any other
conversation don't have to wait till the
audience participation part if you have
a
thought or a question or
something related to what's going on i
would say you know just raise your hand
shout it out we are
this is like a dynamic
uh you know i was not an overly scripted
panel
so anyway you know
all right let's embrace the fact that
we're in uh
in the same room together
um
cool okay so i'm gonna i'm gonna start
off um
super strange pitch that like kind of
weird beating
it's like a semitone or something
anyway
it's the cricket sounds yeah
a lot
okay let's start with like uh just
like you know we have a couple
philosophers uh
on the stage it's not maybe the everyday
occurrence at the assignment i like to
maybe start with a
you know
question maybe sort of pitched at a sort
of difference of like uh
methodological or like
intellectual tradition so here's here's
maybe um
broadly
um uh
a perspective on what goes on in ml
which is that in some ways um
you know maybe not to the pure
mathematicians in the room but like
relative to
a lot of things that happen in other
scholarship in ml there's a part of what
takes place
that is rather
super concrete and precise
and then there's the
very often
like uh
you know an introduction that's written
that sort of
does the work of saying how if at all it
relates to anything in the world that we
care about like the little part that is
where the prose is carrying the
arguments
that is um
let's say at best highly variable
depending on who the author is but a
very often kind of
you know
somewhat haphazard people sort of maybe
like attention in a disciplinary fashion
until like seeking clarity is maybe
concentrated on the the technical part
of the paper and not on the conceptual
part of the paper
and maybe one um
perspective on what's gone wrong in some
of the interpretability
world is that you have
a discipline that is sort of a
constitutionally not in the business of
honing in on fuzzy concepts
um
suddenly like that's taken center stage
it's like that's that's where the action
is
and suddenly like maybe we're like
collectively going to pieces and i see
sort of you know obviously philosophy is
a big tense and there's some very
technical parts of philosophy i'd say
that like philosophy broadly maybe
has uh it's closer to the comfort zone
it seems to me to be in the business of
seeking precision and clarity even in
these
you know
broader conceptual spaces and
i guess you know in in some sense like
it's kind of a broad question but i
guess like in some sense like i'm
curious for your perspective on like
maybe whether it's like what you see
going wrong on the ml side
or even just sort of maybe what um
lessons learned like what lessons that
like the philosophical tradition has to
offer to machine learning people on how
to keep these kinds of
conversations um
on track
i get to go first um
yeah so
i mean i think
okay um
i mean i think it's
a really good um an important
observation uh that there
is a tendency and we see this with
interpretability we see with
explainability we see it with bias
um and fairness this idea that uh the
the concept becomes what we can measure
and quantify
as opposed to
what we can measure and quantify as an
operationalization or a precisification
or an approximation
of the vague fuzzy concept and so here i
think there's real value
not just in
say what philosophers often do but but
what we see for example in linguistics
where there's a long tradition of taking
the idea of semantics which can be vague
and qualitative in certain kinds of ways
and trying to say here is a
a useful model right use the old
statistical thing all models are wrong
but some are useful
um
and and to say
we should not be trying to say what
interpretability is
we should be trying to say here are
a set of operationalizations
that are very useful
in thinking about in what an
interpretation or an interpretable model
is or what an explanation might be
um and so
sort of never losing sight of the fact
that the
concept that we care about
is not equal to the technical machinery
that we deploy
i will say you know philosophers often
forget that there's real value in
technical machinery right so the the we
also want to avoid the contrary converse
problem
which is saying well the technical is
not identical with it's not exactly what
we had in mind so therefore we shouldn't
even bother
and i think that that's where
the most interesting but also the
hardest work is is to sit between those
two perspectives
and sort of simultaneously be able to
keep in one's head
um
the value of and the tech
and the use of the technical
while never
you know essentially falling prey to the
the fiction that this is all there is
um and i don't you know and that says i
actually don't think philosophers are
are special we we tend to people who are
philosophically trained i would argue
often fall prey to that converse problem
but it's why the multidisciplinary work
can be so powerful because you do have
these people with you know seen to
mention diversity of approaches
in his talk and i think that that's
really key here is having
you know somebody at the table who's
always saying yes but how can we make
this more precise well someone else is
saying yes but how do we not lose sight
of
the somewhat vague perhaps slightly
incoherent concept that's driving the
work
yep just uh
does this work
or is it
too far
echoing what uh david said i think uh
i think actually maybe cognitive
scientists are typically
in a good situation of thinking more
seriously about construct validity or
the validity of the constructs that they
use
i think philosophers are
maybe what they can offer is their
comfort with the
lack of clarity in the concepts but
i share some of
david's i think maybe this this wasn't
your concern but some of the things that
sometimes you can get also stuck in
conceptual analysis and
kind of uh
be
quite
resistant to any type of
operationalization at all so this
diversity of perspective is definitely
important but and in many cases
interpretability but also fairness which
again we see
in many cases of papers starts in the
name of precision so like this is what
we mean by fairness but it's unclear
exactly whether that translates to the
concerns of the kind of animates the
work in the paper so i think both fields
actually can learn from each other and
from empirical disciplines that are in
the routine uh
case of
operationalizing foreign concepts but
keeping this distance
thanks um
so i guess one thing that maybe came up
different ways in both of your talks is
something about
the the contingent factors that are not
necessarily
captured just in say the measurements in
your data set
that influence what what would
constitute even uh
um
and let alone an interpretation even
like the
the rough sort of form that it would
even take
um
and you know so so you know you talk
about goals um
xenon you kind of talked about
the system in which it's being deployed
and
so there's this question like of um
it's
there there's this perspective of of
interpretation as being this very
contingent contextually driven
um
or certainly interpretation of being
this contextually
situated object
and then there is a discipline
that is sort of
um context agnostic which is the one of
developing a sort of
um
what it was hoped to be general purpose
machinery
and so i guess
uh how if at all are these reconciled
but like is there to be general purpose
machinery
um
is it just is it so limit like is it a
fool's errand like where where do you
sort of see
if anything the role of a kind of
general-purpose
interpretability discipline
uh
i i
i am i think of the camp of uh
thinking that
things are so goal dependent in certain
cases and use dependent but
trying to come up with the unified
interpretability machinery for all of
these different purposes and goals
is a full zero
but i do think that in
just if you have a maybe a set of
constraints a particular domain and a
particular aim and in many cases we do
have this and a particular set of
limitations
we know that
decision makers in this domain
regularly or typically or systematically
fall prey to this type of limitations
then i do think that
you can choose which of those general
uh domain machinery is actually suitable
for that type of domain that type of
data set that type of uh
interactive setting but uh
whether the by gen if by that we mean
that can we then subsume all of these
things together slowly to make them part
of the same science uh i'm not very
confident in that
i think i might be a little more
optimistic okay um
in the sense that
i'm more optimistic that we could come
up with what we might think of as a
general framework
for interpretable
machine learning that has key free
parameters
and those free parameters are going to
be contextual
i am really pessimistic that there's any
that there's going to be a science of
how to set those parameters right but
i think that's where the art is is
recognizing oh this is the goal that we
have here are the relevant contextual
features that specify those parameters
but i i have some optimism much as we've
been able to do with a lot of machine
learning more generally or ai whatever
that's supposed to mean more generally
where
i think
i think we've i don't know my perception
is that as a community we've largely
moved away from the idea that um
that you don't have to talk to subject
matter experts to do machine learning i
mean i i'm old enough to remember a time
that people would have this attitude of
well you know just give me the the
numbers and i'll give you the truth and
there was almost this disdain i'm
thinking here in the mid 2000s um
there's almost a kind of disdain by some
folks
about engaging with people in a
particular domain like why would i have
to talk to those folks just give me the
date and we're good
um and then you know they have to
interpret the model that comes out but
but why would we need to talk
that i think is has faded a lot um i
think that there's a lot more of a
recognition of the importance of working
with subject matter experts to
understand what the data actually mean
um
and
and i think that actually gives me
optimism about the ability to have
methods that are in some sense um
you know their domain agnostic in as
much as they don't make intrinsic
reference to the domain but these free
parameters the contextual variables that
have to be specified
do pick out the
as it were right parts of the domain so
i
i don't think we can get to a world
where you can just do interpretable ml
and you don't have to know anything
about what the numbers correspond to
that yeah that's a fool's errand um but
the idea that that
that interpretability could permit
of
precise operationalization
much as notions of say independence
which is actually despite the fact that
usual time statistics is a kind of vague
fuzzy notion this idea of two things
being two variables being independent of
each other
there's a qualitative sense that is
approximately operationalized by
statistical tests
whatever your preferred method is
um
i'm optimistic that we might be able to
do something similar for
interpretability
it's not going to be a automate it press
the button and walk away the human
always is going to have to be playing a
critical role
but i see shai's trying to wants to jump
in yeah i mean
i i'm kind of
impressively you just
implicitly you seem to imply
that there is this set of parameters
which are generic
and now the specific domains will just
require setting the values of those
parameters
and i'm skeptical about the existence of
a generic set of parameters that will be
useful
for a big variety of domains so maybe
if you could give an example of such
parameters that you have in mind or
you know relate to this question of do
you think there really exists a generic
overreaching parameters that now it's
just a matter of setting them up
so
i mean there's a there's a there's a
level of abstraction where
where i think the answer is probably yes
that doesn't mean it's a useful level of
abstraction and if the free parameter is
a is
a set of loss functions from which one
can select
that's not a terribly useful um general
setting uh but i i mean i guess i i see
for example in in my own work we've
found similarities in how we approach
the construction of variables
in the two examples i kept referring to
climate science and neuroimaging that
actually the very same kinds of methods
work
at the sort of schema level we have to
tweak the particular uh kinds of loss
functions we have to bring certain kinds
of domain knowledge in in the sense of
you know these factors can't be related
to each other right we have certain
kinds of background knowledge that we
can we can bring as prior background
so um that that makes me optimistic that
we can at least
that we don't have to do a sort of
bespoke one-off solution for every new
problem
um now
there's a giant middle ground between
everything's a one-off and the one true
entirely encodable in a supercomputer
system um
that's my optimism is that maybe we're a
little bit more over here than over here
but that's an empirical question we just
have to see and it may very well
differ depending on the scientific
domain that we're operating
okay
yeah i kind of agree with david um
there's a hope
that we can find high level principles
so schema to unify things but it's kind
of i would see it as an evolution that
we're going to learn new things and we
might refine it then we might decide
some of the principles we hold dear
might not apply anymore
and to bring up another point i want to
hear from both of you how do you think i
haven't heard
as a high level mention of empirical
evidence
for me somehow both in machine learning
we don't talk
to enough about empirical evidence to
back up
the
whatever interval ability we might be
discussing or
philosophically you know we have two
here
how how much value the modern philosophy
put on
like survey empirical evidence or
forming
concepts rooted in empirical evidence i
feel like there's a lack of reality we
talk to experts they're not exactly
reality either rather something a lot
more objective beyond the experts so
that's one thing the other thing maybe
later cena to continue the discussion we
had earlier
is i'm kind of have the philosophy a
human has to be in charge so it's a bit
disturbing that you think that the
machine should be in charge at the
system level so uh maybe
here later yeah
do you want to talk about that
yeah i mean so
uh
there is
so there's i mean i think there's a
couple of of things
tied up in that first question about
empirical evidence um so one is there is
a pretty rapidly growing community of
people
trying to look at you know
what model classes actually are
interpretable well in the sense of
interpretability means that if i show
this to you know an individual from this
group then they will have the following
kinds of cognitive performance and
cognitive capabilities after interacting
with the model and you do get you know
some of those were the kinds of papers
that cena was was noting um
you get some weird results so people
sometimes trust that this partially
motivated a bit of the question i asked
cena uh people actually will sometimes
trust black box models more than
interpretable models um so we have
empirical data showing that if you give
people an interpretable model they like
it less than if you told them nothing at
all
uh
i mean like it's yeah it's a simple
decision tree yeah it's a two or three
you know level decision tree versus you
tell them it's a horribly complicated
deep neural net and they go yay i like
this now that's
one particular white people
yeah so it is um
so that's exactly the
where i was trying to get to and where
i
i actually have some concern this is the
the negative side the part um that i
makes me worry about having
um
the ability to figure out
sort of very general empirical evidence
for something being interpretable is
exactly
um
let's just think about all of the
choices that go into running one
particular study with one particular
finding we had to say here's what we
mean by interpretability it will have
the following cognitive impacts
here's how we're going to operationally
measure those here's the population in
which we're going to
test them here are the particular models
that we're going to compare maybe if
we'd used a linear model instead of a
shallow decision tree that one would
have given a different reaction and
and now we're into the world which in
cognitive science is the kind of
frustration which is there's always yet
another experiment
and what i think we are lacking right
now and i think this is what your
question was really getting at
we are lacking a way to avoid falling
into the combinatoric mess
that is just running yet another yet
another yet another experiment
um
and you know what what incognito science
saves us from yet another experiment
well by and large theory and often
computationally precise theory
and so now we're back to the very first
question that zach was starting us with
which is how do we have
precise enough theory about what
interpretability means
and what its implications should be what
impacts it should have
without losing sight of the fact that it
isn't equal to this operationalization
now you ask about surveys uh there are
plenty of philosophers who are starting
to do empirical work basically surveying
people about what their concepts are
i think most of that is not very useful
because i think for the most part people
are pretty bad the the kinds of concepts
that we want
to get insight into how humans think
about them
tend to be the ones that we don't have a
whole lot of introspective access to
so i for example don't think that asking
people what do you think causation means
works very well you can ask people
to describe or assess particular
situations you can ask them to exhibit
behaviors
but asking them to introspect on it
doesn't work very well and that's what a
lot of the philosophical so-called
experimental philosophy work is in that
vein
um so i do think that that this is a
place where we need better theory
we need
uh constraints about what
what we're looking for in the empirical
evidence those constraints should come
from a mix of philosophy psychology
machine learning uh and it's an open
challenge i mean i wish i could give a
nice clean answer but the reality i
think right now is your instinct to look
for the empirical evidence is right it's
not there to the extent it needs to be
and part of the challenge is that we
we're sort of still in almost a kind of
behaviorist world of
just kind of running yet another
experiment to see what are the patterns
we're even seeing
and um i
think it's more likely to be successful
if we start with a bit more theory
grounded
especially in the space of explanations
grounded in what we know from a few
centuries of work on philosophical work
on the nature of explanation what what
it ought to be to be a good explanation
well i think we could really benefit
from
more of that kind of guidance
well um all right i'm just gonna ask one
and also i just wanted to record that
point that i think you you raised
with whom right which makes the as your
point of users and the population on
which this is supposed to be important
very important right we have the same
type of thing in neuroscience
a lure of neuroscientific explanations
that
mean nothing and are taken to be good
explanations by uh kind of lay people
but any expert would think that this is
pretty bad explanation so
kind of different uh category of people
but uh
also i i should say that i really like
this point about the need for having
increased theory instead of relying on
people's uh survey responses uh i think
this is another thing that we see in
cognitive science a lot in people's uh
causal judgment and counter factual
judgments when they have to rate which
contractual judgment do you think is
more uh probable
typically that
i think at least i think you have
written on causal judgment part i've
written on contractual judgment part
but many of the models that try to
explain people's behavior in that way
are actually not very successful trying
to figure out like why is it that actual
causal judgments are this way until we
go at least at a more functional level
decide what is it that we want this to
do for us
and are those judgments in line with
that so
this idea that we need theory to kind of
put some type of constraint on what it
is that we want to do i think is also
borne out in different uh
domains that people actually similar
causal contractual similar to people's
intuitions on explanations
i think here too asking what is it that
we want exactly this explanation to do
uh it's going to be very useful
well so i want to give the one question
and then i'll get to um back to the
audience uh one thing that and this came
up when we were uh
for
pretending to be unrehearsed so we
really had a lengthy email thread of at
least two emails
and um
well and this is i think it's like a a
broader uh
like a common recurring question is
there's this sort of
what actually is the object
you know to which the explanation or
interpretation pertains
and um
is it that we are describing the some
some underlying phenomena in the world
or is this you're explaining the model
and
there's a couple parts here one one is
that
um
you know did there is a sort of
slippage of aims of its
i mean
let alone what what would mean to
explain the phenomena explain the world
there is uh a way in which it's
unclear and often slipping even within
the very same paper from section a
section or from the introduction to what
they actually do
and there's also maybe a way in which
sometimes there's like an element of
hiding the ball so like uh someone says
no we're just explaining the model it's
like why are you explaining the model so
we can make better decisions and you say
well
what what now now this has to be
something tethering now insofar as the
thing's explaining the model there's a
belief that this explanation of the
model enables you to make a better
decision in the real world there's some
tie back to ultimately at the end of the
day
something you know
so i guess the high level question
is sort of
uh
do you believe this distinction do you
buy it if you do buy it
um
are these fundamentally different
problems from each other and should they
be lumped together should they be split
apart entirely and if you
you know
or or maybe if you don't buy it maybe
make an argument for why you don't buy
it
i i do by this so you mean that uh
understanding the model versus
understanding the world at a basic level
yeah yes of course i do by the
difference i think there's a big
difference the model uh
among other things you may
rely on properties and relations uh that
are not really there in the world but i
think so i think that it's kind of
actually easy in a way to say that it's
mistake to say that i'm giving
contractual explanation
and then switching back and forth as if
your counterfactual explanation is about
the word versus about the model because
these two things are not the same
something could have been different in
the model board but not in the world
right
but i think there's actually kind of a
challenge in terms of completely
separating them uh when we think about
some of the use cases right
so in some of these cases when you think
i would want to have a contractual
explanation for recourse
right i want to give it to someone so
that in the future maybe they can change
their behavior and they get it
on the one hand we have to
know how that change of behavior will
have impacts in the world on the other
hand we have to know how that changes
the situation in the model
they come apart clearly
but we want it to be connected too so if
i say that oh you change your behavior
this way the model will make a different
prediction about you but they go in the
board they change their behavior and
then they're through some other causal
pathway they change some other things
that actually the model will not make a
different uh
decision about them i don't know if it's
clear right right because the model is
depending on some other thing so i think
they're obviously different but
right i think one way that i think about
it in that particular example is you say
okay i'm just providing a counter here
this is a a different input that would
elicit a different prediction
and this is actionable insofar as
provides you with some
ability to
impact your own outcomes and then the
the the slippage is that
if all we were doing was training a
predictive model
in a way that wasn't tied to in any way
to causal structure in the real world
then this is sort of like an incoherent
practice because if you're you know
if you're out there giving say this kind
of like remedy then it's like it sort of
invalidates the model in the first place
unless you were in the business in the
very first place of developing a model
that was somehow um accounting for say
the mechanisms of strategic behavior or
something like that so it's like
right
i haven't i guess what i haven't seen is
like a pure example where really
the whole story hangs together unless we
circle back and realize that in the
first place we really need to be
actually having like a model of
mechanism in the world
well so so let me
let me distinguish two different issues
that i think might be getting blurred
together here right so the first is
sure you go i mean just here's a really
simplistic picture of what what we're
all doing um there's the world which
generates data which leads to a model
and when we think about interpretability
um
we sometimes think about the fact that
the data is not the same as the model if
we do sometimes distinguish between say
interpretable data an interpretable
model or if you think about you know
folks
like the kind of ml that i do which is
causal discovery algorithms where we are
explicitly trying to say we're not
trying to learn
a model of the data we want to learn a
model of the kinds of things that could
have produced data like these we do that
um on the ml side we we do some i mean
there is some work on you know
if you know that there's a selection
bias in your data generation process how
do you compensate for that
i don't think we have that on the
interpretability side i don't think we
have methods
in essence to say
if i imagine just you know
contrary to fact imagine i knew all of
the measurement and selection biases
going from the world to my data
and i can choose whatever method i want
to go from the data to the model
could i then somehow link together
interpretability of the model and
interpretability of the word i mean they
obviously just said they obviously come
apart
um i can have a model that's perfectly
interpretable that is a model of a world
that is incomprehensible to me
we might think that you know
an economic model is interpretable but i
can't understand the quantum mechanical
model or quantum mechanical reality that
underlies economics or something i don't
know like that
um
so
i do think there's actually a really
potentially interesting empirical
question which is could you if you knew
something about the measurement setup if
you knew something about the biases
of various sorts that go from the world
to the data
could you actually sort of reverse
engineer those to get from
interpretable model
of the interpretable world like could we
start to link these together and i don't
know that we know i mean that that's
just an open technical question i have
no idea how we would how one would go
about doing that um but it's at least
seems to me an interesting one to ask
so that that's issue one a second issue
i think is the one that you were
bringing up there zach which is
there's also the challenge that if i use
a model to make decisions i'm now acting
on the world potentially
and so there's also the problem that the
very act
of using an interpretable model
is going to impact the kind of world
that i'm now
measuring in the next round of data
collection
and in fact you could imagine that
i could use a model that makes the world
less interpretable or in fact more
commonly the use of models makes the
world more interpretive
and that kind of dynamic i don't think
we've got a good handle on certainly in
social phenomena
if you start to use models and start to
use algorithms to govern the allocation
of resources for example
people will adapt their behavior to make
sure they get access to it that is
people will regularize their own
behavior
and that feedback loop means that the
very use of an of an interpretable model
can lead to
social structures that are more
interpretable because we humans will
adapt we're responsive to incentives we
will adapt our behavior
to conform to what the model expects
and thereby regularize our own behavior
and make it more interpretable right so
there's a whole other set of i think
really interesting feedback loops
especially with social systems
that is about the dynamics of deploying
a model but i think that's also separate
from this question of the distinction
between the interpretability of the
model and the interpretability of the
world
i'm tempted to go on attention about
looping effects of human kinds but uh uh
i have uh
different feedback loopers
oh cool uh so so i'll i'll go to uh
giles
um
did i mess it up all right great thank
you
well i'll rely on you to repeat the
question or i can get a microphone
i don't know if it occurred out there in
zoom land but the start of the the panel
there was a joke about having a couple
of philosophers on stage so we'd start
with plato and i therefore want to ask
about dialogue
but more specifically i think in both of
your talks there was this underlying
structure of saying well there may be
different view ways of looking at this
problem either from
two different you know criteria for the
way you want to structure a model that
you can understand or or from a human
versus machine and both of them really
require an interaction in fact the
question
um
for david from from joe halpern here was
well okay if we have these two models
surely there is a lattice and an
intersection or union of these concepts
that we can base this on
and if i think of
decision support machine learning i
really think of that as being something
along the lines of i want a dialogue
between
this
machine learning algorithm and whoever
is ultimately making the decision
not so much on the oh which one of these
people do i trust but in terms of you
know the the human decision maker saying
is that a decision from the machine
learner that i
that i actually trust
um
and and so there's a question of are we
thinking about interpretability in far
too much or explanations in a far too
static sense as opposed to being
some form of more interactive model
and and in which case you know we're all
kind of doing this wrong uh
not everybody i've seen a little bit but
uh and and but but is there a and this
is a kind of fuzzy question but we've
got philosophers on stage so so is there
a way in which we should be focusing
differently
yes um
no
so to to elaborate a bit i mean yes i
think um
if we think about
let's take exponent i know this is
interpretable let me just focus on the
explanation for the moment if we think
about explanations if i if cena says to
me or if my daughter says to me why did
something happen and i give her an
explanation if she's unhappy about that
she can ask a follow-up question
um and so
uh now which follow-up question she
would ask is going to depend on
why she wants the explanation for
example i might be able to do a good job
of anticipating
what
what in you know why she's asking me for
this why question uh in which case i
might be able to give something
satisfactory at the outset
but it is important in terms of the
social interactions and in terms of the
the intellectual
dynamics of the person receiving the
explanation or the person who's
receiving the model
it is important that they can ask
follow-up questions i think that that's
absolutely right um
now
when i think about what what we're all
engaged in i think
where i would maybe push back a little
is i i think that and and the reason i
mentioned the being able to anticipate
what the explanation requester really
cares about um is
if you
design develop
deploy your system appropriately
you may well be able to ascertain that
in a way that you don't have to provide
real time dynamic and interactive
capacities
now that involves
co-designing with the people who are
going to be interacting with your system
co-developing with them co-evaluating
with them uh it's not something that i
can you know just sort of sit in my
philosophies arm chair and say oh here's
what people clearly want that's you know
the way that we end up with a whole lot
of
systems that don't serve the needs of
the users right so there does i think
need to be
interaction
in the development of these systems i
don't know that it needs to happen real
time post deployment it might need to
there will be context where it would
need to but i do think there are other
ways of interaction needs to occur at
some point it doesn't necessarily have
to be only at the end though you might
be able to have a system that does not
have interactive components because you
did all that leg work at the beginning
but it's it is and and that kind of leg
work i think there are a lot more people
who are doing the kind of that kind of
co-design um still not nearly enough
but but more
okay so here's a question from ruth
and she's asking
following up on david's contrasting
between philosophers focusing on
abstract concepts and accepting them not
being precisely defined and computer
scientists focusing on technical
solutions and potentially confusing them
for the concepts of themselves
is there a more abstract way of
developing criteria for whether a
technique is useful towards the abstract
concept and dead draw has a comment
which we can get back to so
you guys want to comment now
so
so the question is are there
ways to know which sort of which
direction one should be trying to move
or
um
i mean what one part is exactly the kind
of code design you know we're just you
know actually figuring out
whether something is useful for
particular
uh groups
you know in particular uses um
i think there
there's a certain amount of
uh importance
in
always
sort of
i mean i'm trying not to just be a
philosopher and say you always have to
go back up to that level i mean so um
there's always value i think in doing
that um the key is
is to do it dynamically so
if you think of it in a sort of very
simplistic way is there's the sort of
qualitative vague
conceptual level and there's the precise
technical level
sort of being able to oscillate back and
forth in terms of which you hold fixed
and which you're working on i think is
really critical because there are times
that technical work has revealed
really important conceptual differences
that had been lost or had been blurred
or elided in the philosophical work and
then we realized oh wait this is
actually a really important distinction
um i mean a classic one would be the
distinction between uh evidential and
causal decision theory which sort of
reshapes
a lot of the philosophical debates in
action theory when people go wait a
second this is actually a really
important distinction
um
and and i think that
we see some similar things happening in
the in the causation literature
it it's happened counterfactuals right
so um
i think that the key is is less about
any particular method for moving between
them and more about this sort of
oscillating dynamic of what you're
holding fixed in a moment
so these are commented on rue's question
she said measurement modeling is a
useful technique
see jacob's abigail z and hannah
wallet
measurement and fairness in preceding
the acm 2021 um fairness and
accountability
yeah definitely transparency so explicit
modeling of what you're i mean so
you know i think
a broader thing there is is being
intentional and reflective about what
you're doing i mean not simply going
well this is what we do in our lab so
let's just keep doing that um which
sounds really simple in banal but is
hard to do in everyday life uh if you're
you know it's sort of like being in a
startup where you've got a ship you got
to get that paper out the door
and um you don't want to have
you know the proverbial paralysis by
analysis where you're spending all your
time analyzing things you never actually
do
uh but
also never being blind about about the
choices that are being made along the
way
i think it was like the first thing i
ever heard and uh moved i moved to like
san francisco from new york and
wound up at like the startup world it's
like kind of the first analysis
paralysis
chobani
so uh i agree that uh the
uh the loss function or who's using an
interpretability tool might strongly
dictate like how we design it but i
think one thing that i feel like at side
steps is that in many cases we might not
have a choice like in a particular for a
particular application you have multiple
stakeholders who have all to be involved
like going back to cena's example for
example for instance where like the
complementarity thing might require the
model to be not interpretable but like
from a social justice perspective maybe
it's like it could probably be very
problematic to tell one group of people
we're like making your decisions based
on human and the other that we're using
this uninterpretable model to make your
decisions for you and so i wonder what
you think about this
and of course there are many more
stakeholders involved in like typical
applications so then is it hopeless for
us to think about interpretability at
all for a bit even for a particular tool
let's say or a particular model
i think that's a great question uh
but i i wouldn't say it's hopeless for
for
a number of reasons one is that i think
in many of those cases uh what we might
mean by interpretability are actually
kind of very different uh so what let's
say in the case of complementarity
you know i said in that case that one
implication might be that in some
senses for the user if the model is not
interpretable in
some sense
it might be better for complementarity
but it might be interpretable in another
sense from the perspective of the person
who's designing
this team namely
just like take it as a like a
hypothetical example
what type of features does this model
rely on and is it different kind of
features in humans
so this is one thing but then there's
the other thing is that
i think for many of the things that
because in most of these cases
interpretability in this very variety of
senses
is also a means to an
end there are often other means that can
get us to those ends
in many cases of social justice i think
is a good example i think
i am not convinced that model
interpretability like that is
interpretability of the predictive model
in itself in particular sense
is
a better means than many other types of
things for promoting social justice
concerns i think
having regular auditing practices
having uh kind of access the data
annoying co-design that has come up
knowing
like if i tell somebody that this
feature is very kind of important in the
way that i make my decision but they
have no idea what that feature means
they have had no role in designing that
feature which is like in many cases
actually this happens like what who's a
good student that's why you were not
selected right
so i'm a little bit more hopeful there
because i think in many cases where
things seem to be coming apart and like
literature on complementarity as you
said is like a great example of that but
some people say oh explain
explainability approaches are actually
bad for complementarity
i think
it's
actually different senses of
interpretation are meant there are
different users for them so if something
that is bad for the user might not be
bad for the person who designs it and in
certain other cases just like we just
have better aims uh social justice
fairness one example
so we can't put these things that look
on the face of it to be in tension with
each other
together in some other cases we don't
even need some of them because we have
alternative pathways of getting to what
we want wow
my ass question maybe uh brings together
some notion of
a few things we're talking about about
modeling about mechanism about evidence
and about complementarity
so
um
you know anything like a recurring theme
here is a very often sort of saying well
let's say let's say we're in a
complementary setting we care about how
well a human performs at
some tasks
i say this could be our fitness function
to guide the choice of what it is that
constitutes a good explanation in that
sense
so now we have some data and where we
take no stand on where the data comes
from
what we're trying to predict how it's
related to the task but you know we just
would say someone's got a model of
something
based on something else you know predict
something from something
we think we think sort of like you know
and i would say well you know
if you can somehow take that model and
and and get it to poop out an
explanation and it helps the human
to do whatever is this other task we've
taken no stand on how it's related to
what we were modeling but if somehow
we're able to do a good job at that
we could say it's at least in this
contextual sense uh a good explanation
so the problem
to me with a lot of this stuff is that
you say then where
well like sort of like where are we
searching for hypotheses
like first of all what convinces us in
the first place that this is the the why
would we even accept in the first place
is the right data to look at or that we
should take this model and try to
explain it or that it has anything to do
with the task at hand very often it's a
bit dubious
but let's just say we even take that for
granted that somehow there's some fuzzy
relationship between
you know
what the neural network is trying to do
in the task we just you know we're not
clarifying it i say where do we search
for
like what are the candidates for what
would constitute the thing we would show
to the human
and what people turn to
strikes me as just throwing spaghetti at
the wall so like lime shop
grad cam
class activation vectors all this stuff
it strikes me that there is no reason
to my knowledge they failed every sanity
check ever thrown at any of them they
failed it almost every the best you
could say about
the uh
evidence for usefulness in any real
world task is
um
like
uh
almost every test showed it wasn't
useful but some were ambivalent
and yet somehow like this is this is the
starting point you see you know we get
to the point of well let's go for the
empirical evidence what do we do well
the starting point is these are the
candidates
lime shop this stuff
and so we're in this weird situation
which is we've got this like you know
big data these models we we want
empirical evidence for our explanation
is useful but our hypotheses for like
what what is the universe of possible
explanations to look at
strikes me as sort of like
just absolutely
haphazardly chosen like i could have
just said let's look at neuron 417
from layer k
that's your explanation
and it strikes me that it would do
similarly well on nearly every test
that's been thrown at it to all the
other nonsense that we have so just to
end it on us i'd like a panel to be a
little bit
provocative because then we gotta have
discussions over lunch
um
what guides to search for hypotheses
like i i'm willing to buy this sort of
functional like aim-based view
but then what are the candidate you know
interventions here
uh because it strikes me that they can't
be the things we're looking at now so
like what's a better way to do it
well so
i mean i mean the first thing to say is
one of the challenges of a more
functional approach from the
philosophical psychological side is it
doesn't tell you very much about the
potential interventions to try it tells
you measures to know if you've succeeded
not necessarily the things to try
but i guess i want to push back i mean i
don't think that these methods are
are complete gibberish it's not the same
as pick some random neuron in a deep net
um
but but actually more importantly what i
would say is
that that part of what
part of my reaction to it is to say
yeah that's research i mean if we knew
the answer then we wouldn't be bothering
to do the research
so the real
issue that i have
is the speed with which some of these
methods
have moved from a research conjecture
to being implemented as this is the way
we you know like let's regulate on this
basis like that's that's the error i
think it's not that we've got these
different ideas and we're testing them
that's the nature of research we don't
know what the answer is it's not like we
know it
and and and you know it's like i know it
i'm just keeping it from right i mean
are we trying to go up with better
methods yeah lots of people are working
on that we want to do better
the worry or one of the big worries i
have on the ethics policy sciences like
the scientists found the chemical
it failed the cellular studies it failed
the animal trials
and my doctor says here let me
personally get a human trial anyway and
it also failed it and now it's standard
okay
a little yeah i mean it's not maybe
there's like a small slight signal that
might be because we've done you know p
hacking to get there right um
and and so
how do we
set up uh professional
standards uh standards in
the you know industry of best practices
that says
you don't just use this because it's the
thing that you read a paper you saw a
cool paper at nurips last year and three
months later we're going to deploy it in
production code i mean that's
that's
i think the real sin not that we don't
know the answers yet
but that
despite not knowing the answers these
are getting picked up and adopted and
having really transformative impacts on
people's lives you can't have analysis
paralysis you know you gotta you gotta
move yes yeah exactly
uh
uh okay cheyenne jordan and then we will
oh okay we've got three questions three
hands and they're both looking all look
really eager and then let's try to keep
the last one you know uh kind of uh kurt
and then we will uh
eat uh
seven hour lunch okay
so so they would completely agree with
you but i think
one aspect here that we have to take
into account is that the sociological
aspect i mean the the industry the media
they are looking for positive answers
they need an answer they are not happy
with
saying we don't have an answer we don't
know so they jump on anything that may
look like an answer and there's kind of
a positive feedback loop
loop i mean the person who developed
this
vague system is very happy that's being
deployed the person who is deploying it
is very happy that there is an answer
and there is a sociological dynamics
that pushes thoughts immature solutions
and boosts them and
kind of tones down
negative criticism
yeah i mean i think
there are a lot of people who have very
strong incentives to
pick something and move with it even if
it's not
the right thing uh i completely agree
and
and that leads to you know a whole lot
of really difficult questions about
regulation policy practice that
um i do think there's a you know
that's another kind of thing i work on
and i think there's a lot of us trying
to trying to do better um but it's tough
given the incentive structures that are
out there
so
what i was hoping you would say in
response to zach's question and i'm
gonna give you the chance to either say
or reject
um is that you know you alluded to the
fact that there's like a long literature
in philosophy about explanations and how
they work which maybe hasn't had so much
uptake in this community and one thing
you could imagine that doing is giving
us a lot of options of what kinds of
things can count as explanations i mean
it's sort of
hopefully i'm wondering if you think
that literature existing in philosophy
can provide useful clues as to what
kinds of things to look for as
explanations rather than
doing the kinds of things that zach is
critiquing
i i i think they're both yeah that's it
i think that's a great point i i do want
to say that i think in many cases when
people say interpretability
explainability it's unclear exactly
whether we want the explanation or
something else about the model that we
would want to know because it's useful
for some uh so
i do want to flag like the getting uh
too connected to the similarity in terms
explainability and explanation
philosophy might be
a little bit too much because most views
in plastic right now explanation is
causal like in the different senses but
i i think there's something else that
you say that i really like which i think
david also mentioned
which is
i think it's important to
separate the aim the measures of success
for that aim and the current methods
that we have for getting there i think
the current methods might not be very
good and i think there's another
way there's always this like backlash
against interpretability as such
where because some people like think
that interpretability methods are not
very good which is true
in many cases
they think that like the entire aim of
having it like searching for some type
of interpretability explainability is
like mistaken and i think
that is also wrong credit it's just so i
think one
broader way of putting that is
maybe the connection can help
clarify what it is that success would
look like for what type of aims might we
want
this and what does success look like
from the perspective of that aim from
this kind of functional perspective
uh again it doesn't say like what the
method is which is like the task of the
research but at least it keeps uh
makes
our movements towards whatever
we want kind of more precise
yeah and
absolutely we should be looking
everywhere to get better ideas
i mean not just philosophy not just
cognitive science i mean uh people who
work in industrial organization
work on how you design
uh institutions companies organizations
so as you say as to have clear lines of
responsibility and accountability and
decision making authority
well that's how do i make a job how do i
make ibm
interpretable so i understand what's
going on in that company right that's
there's a different a completely
different historical tradition of
interpretability that's looking at
social organizations and which social
organizations can we make sense of and
which ones do we look and say this is
just a mess and we're never going to be
able to figure out who made the wrong
decision and so who gets fired or who
gets promoted right so
in that sense i
i'm a pragmatic anything that could help
get us better models i am
let's look to those traditions uh 100
agreement
hi uh good comment so far um
i am thinking that um a lot of this a
lot of discussion on interpretability in
ml really boils
like that we have had really boils down
to what humans understand as
interpretable what we think
is what we can understand and explain to
each other what we can communicate
and i feel that this
what we can do now is a result of what
we have been trained over the years um
in the sciences uh and um
in humanities and so on
for example
plots
um images
geometric figures first order logic
these are examples that we can explain
to each other and understand and we can
um i mean
i don't know if these are constructs or
maybe these are just
ways of um
ways of making sure that we reach a
common conclusion
so
um are these
ml tools like lime sharp
and grad camp just
trying to
i guess
show the characteristics of the ml model
in ways that
i mean in ways that us humans can
understand
should we try to create tools that
create plots and
images or should we also you know
think about other interpretability tools
that go beyond what we can
currently
that we are currently trained for
um
so
so when i when i teach about
interpretability and explanations um one
of the key distinctions i always draw is
between
uh something like say
a post-hoc
clarification you know the
lime call it right something like that
and
um and then people talk about well the
the model itself is interpretable like
it's a simple linear model but then i
think there's actually a third class
which is um
i can interpret zach's behavior
without i'm not well all right i can
interpret cena's behavior um and it's
not because i have a local approximation
to him
it's not because i can look inside at
the neurons that generate his behavior
and and have an in seo that's not an
interpretable his brain is not
interpretable it's because
um i have the right theory of him
roughly speaking a kind of you know
belief desire folk psychology which at
the level of what we're all
you know most human behavior that's
perfectly what does he don't want um
yeah what does lena what does cena
believe uh what therefore what is he
going to intend and what does he value
to do the decision between his
intentions
um he's got something to do with
liverpool and i don't need i don't
actually need very much data about cena
to generate a very rich model a very
rich interpretation of him um
that's something that's a cognitive
universal to the best of our knowledge
every normally developing human
uh
you know for whatever that exactly means
um
develops the ability to rapidly generate
interpretations and revise those
interpretations of other humans
uh other intentional agents
so i think they're what you're pointing
towards is you know maybe what we should
do
is instead of worrying about the
restricting the model we should restrict
the behavior i mean maybe we should
restrict our robots to only be able to
act in ways that they are interpretable
as if they have beliefs and desires who
cares how they're actually coded under
the hood
but they have to exhibit behaviors that
are interpretable in this way so that's
a completely different kind of approach
roboticists tend not to be fans of
people saying that kind of thing but
um i think it points to this idea that
we
we need to i think be more flexible
about
whether it's generating new methods
whether it's
taking advantage of the cognitive
universals for example visual perception
and pattern finding in certain kind of
visual scenes i think this goes to the
complementarity issues that cena was
raising um you know human computer
interaction is exactly the kind of
complementarity that cena uh was talking
about and a lot of that is how do i
present information in ways that people
understand it given our particular weird
biases our weird cognitive systems
now
the one place that i would
i won't say push back but i i think
um i i am all in on interpretation like
that those are about
what we humans need in that sense i
definitely want to keep the human
centered i don't
sometimes people will talk about well
but how do we have uh ai cis or machine
learning systems that are interpretable
by other machine learning systems and i
go i'm not i don't know how to think
about that
um so yeah it's
what counts as interpretable explanation
those are going to be distinctive to our
weird cognitive architectures
but even relative to that i think
there's a lot of opportunities that we
haven't been exploring yet
like the intentional stance isn't it
like pretty simple to describe what all
the mob like isn't there some sense in
which there's one banal like
explanation of all the models that you
know
given uh some
set of
implicitly you know undeclared uh
inductive biases and given some finite
sample
this label is the one that seemed more
likely given the input
condition on the data set that you
observe and that this is all there in
some sense like that is this is the only
aim of the model and that everything
else is sort of uh
is is a sort of a gross
anthropomorphization of what these
models are doing
i mean
i i wouldn't say it's an
anthropomorphization um also uh you know
specificity matters so um you know
am i able to make sense of the prior
inductive biases for example um i can
write things down mathematically it
doesn't mean that they make sense
so
that's and and whether we care
is in that sense a human centered
question
but i think it's an appropriate question
to ask
hey um
i just would like to thank our panelists
for uh speaking and
[Applause]
stepping up and feeling a little more
spaced and we anticipated having uh and
for making the trek uh
so really great to see you all in person
um
you have a luxurious lunch break ahead
of you so i hope you'll
all stuff yourselves so we're restarting
at 3 p.m pacific time in this room
yes
yes we're getting confirmation
all right